ble Kev we in here man Bole Kev podcast
shout out to the Bay Area such a
wonderful place to visit such a
wonderful place to
go so many talented young artists who
have graced the bootle Kev podcast
platform we have another guy Fairfield
yep yep in the building Kai band is here
welcome sir what you got going on before
we have you rap man plug your [__] sh
[__] just out here in La coasting you
feel me [__] with my [__] DB Draco
little [__] going on event you feel me
rocking out tonight we [__] around
though you feel me all well listen man
let's get to it we going we going to
play some Bay Area [__] for you to rap
up come
on sh my [__] lar
[Music]
J some slow [__]
though [__] serious look hey
I'm on M Road Shopping pink perk popping
it's walk in my cup I make and I dropped
her at BOS NOA give me steak with the
lobster what's in my cup this [__]
straight from the doctor I get bans it's
a habit a [__] living lavish my [__]
quick to flly in bags home that be
trapping in the Trap House 100 p in the
Attic don't be playing on my phone let's
just money transactions forign whip
driving skirting through the rain hard
black ttin on every whip like Bruce
Wayne I sell white to my white boy his
name Shane this [__] get serious in the
field it's not no game so you got to
take your time with this [__] [__] H
blunt EAS my mind in this [__] it might
be a long ride in this [__] here where
I go I got my fire and my whip they just
free my brother free Little Ray on seven
Circle we was stuck in every day trap
house for seven days he don't know about
them days Mo was getting printed you
don't know about them ways [__] so you
got to take your time with this [__]
brother blunt he's my mind in this [__]
it might be a long ride in this [__]
everywhere I go I got my fire in this
whip there we go k b man appreciate you
pulling up you got any uh music dropping
soon anything out people go hell yeah we
got a mixtape out now it's serious on
all platforms it's always serious you
feel me new [__] coming next year 2024
we F to take over no cap appreciate you
pulling up man oh there we go fire hey
you just watched another freestyle
brought to you by the good Folks at LRG
godamn it shout out to LRG all right go
use the promo code bootleg right now on
their website l-r-g.com say 40% off at
checkout 40% off at check out use that
promo code and we got another freestyle
coming ASAP